thomas pesquet est restée confinée
pendant six mois à bord de la station
spatiale internationale et il y retourne
à la fin de l'année 2021 mais comment la
fusée qu'il emmène sa rage celle du sol
comme un ballon de baudruche qui
s'envolent l'air qui s'échappe génère
une force dirigée vers le bas par
réaction une force identique s'exerce
dans la direction opposée
action réaction quel ballon s'envole une
fusée n'expulse pas de l'air mais une
masse importante de gaz issues de la
combustion est très rapidement
l'échappement génère une force dirigée
vers le bas par réaction une force
identique et générer vers le haut une
force qu'on appelle la poussée et pour
revenir et bien thomas pesquet utilisant
une capsule de les confiner si vous avez
aimé cette capsule n'hésitez pas à
laisser un pouce bleu vous pouvez
également revoir au revoir celle des
jours précédents en cliquant sur le côté
gauche
j'en réalise une nouvelle chaque jour et
pour être sûr de ne louper aucune et
bien abonnez vous et activer la cloche
aller à demain et n'oubliez pas nous
sommes toujours confiné mais on reste en
lien